for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy so
first up as far as the periodic trends
go is atomic size or atomic radius which
is how we measure atomic size before we
mentioned that electrons in an atom can
be infinitely far away from the nucleus
so we ended up saying was that atoms
were taken to be spheres where the
electrons spend ninety percent of their
time that way we can at least imagine an
atom to be sort of a ball with a surface
okay so how do we define a Tomic size
when it comes to measuring it well we
Basin atom-sized on how closely it
associates with another atom of the same
element and this is going to be
different from metals versus non metals
so we'll start off with metals over here
with two aluminum atoms because aluminum
of course is a metal so aluminum being a
metal atom well metal atoms just in
general when they orient themselves
together they form what's called a
crystal lattice okay and in these
crystal lattices we basically have the
atoms sort of surface to surface alright
we can kind of see that here each
spheres surface it's kind of their just
just up against each other like this and
so we do to measure the the radius
between these two two metal atoms we
take the distance from one nucleus to
the other nucleus so here's a nucleus
here's a nucleus we take the distance
between them and in this case for
aluminum the distance is actually 286
pico meters and so we do with that
distance is we take half of it because
half of it would be the distance from
here to here right and so that is the
radius of this
and in this case it would just be to 86
/ 2 which is 143 picometers and so this
is specifically the metallic radius okay
metallic radius the metallic radius is
defined as half the distance between the
nuclei of adjacent atoms in a crystal of
that metal element so here we have a
crystal of aluminum Simon drawn the
whole thing I'm strong two atoms as part
of it but it's half the distance between
the nuclei so next up is non metals
nonmetals and for this we're going to
use two chlorine atoms now chlorine is
actually a diatomic element which means
that its elemental form is CL 2 there's
two atoms that make up the elemental
form of chlorine that's how it exists
naturally okay so it is a diatomic
element and it's really useful because
what we can do is these are two of the
same atom bound together okay and
they're they're a little bit different
it's different than the metallic radius
in that instead of being surface to
surface there is some overlap there's
some overlap and we can see that overlap
right here right because see how they're
kind of overlapping a little bit they're
not surface to surface but the principle
is pretty much the same in terms of how
we measure the radius we take the
distance from one nucleus to the other
and in this case that distance in the
case of chlorine is 199 pico meters and
so half that is ninety nine point five
or approximately 100 picometers now that
that's going to be the atomic radius of
chlorine and since it's a nonmetal we're
going to call this the covalent radius
which might ring a bell if you know
about covalent bonding
so the covalent radius is defined as
half the distance between nuclei of
identical atoms that are covalently
bonded and that's the case here okay now
that's that's particularly useful
because if we measure the atomic radius
of a nonmetal um in its diatomic form
and that same atom binds or two to a
different atom then we can use the fact
that we know this atomic radius to find
out the atomic radius of the other atom
so over here to the right I've got one
carbon atom bound to one chlorine atom
so here this little grey guy right here
is carbon a carbon atom okay and the
green of course is the chlorine chlorine
out so same idea we measure the distance
between the two nuclei nucleus their
nucleus there we measure the distance
between them and in this case it's 177
pico meters well we know that the
chlorine basically provides a 100 pico
meters of that because of this right
here right we know that the length is
this this length right here is 100 pico
meters so the rest of it the rest of
that 177 must be due to carvings atomic
radius so if we have 177 pico meters and
we subtract 100 picometers we're left
with 77 pico meters and that is the
atomic radius of carbon in this case now
one thing to pay attention to is that or
to keep in mind at least is that Adams
don't have solid surfaces they have
electron clouds and because of this
atoms bond differently from compound to
compound ok so the length of the the
distance or the distance between the two
nuclei isn't always going to be the same
so the atomic size or radius depends on
the substance in question which is kind
of we
okay but now that we defined atomic
radius we could basically just say that
the bigger the radius the bigger the
atom right so next up is kind of what's
going on with the trend okay so what's
the trend for atomic size or atomic
radius on the periodic table well it
increases down and to the left okay so
we see that here on the periodic table
it's gonna as we go to the the left the
atomic radius will increase and as we go
down it'll increase so at the bottom
left of the periodic table we have the
largest atoms in the top right with the
smallest atoms so now the question is
why is this well it's due to shielding
electron shielding also you can think
about that as changes in the principle
quantum number N and also effective
nuclear charge effective nuclear charge
often just abbreviated as Z eff okay so
as the principal quantum number n
increases the likelihood that the outer
electrons will be further away from the
nucleus increases right as you increase
the number n you're going up in you're
adding more shells of electrons so the
electrons are more likely to be further
away so as n increases atomic size or
atomic radius increases as well ok
so we can imagine an atom here we got
two protons two neutrons and two
electrons if this is this is shown here
as sort of a 1s to write this would be a
helium atom okay now if I just added
another shell right if I went to the
second energy level I would have more
electrons right they would occupy that
next shell right so as the n increases
what ends up happening is that we have
that other shell right and we also have
these inner these inner electrons right
here sort of shielding the outer
electrons because they repel and so
there's an increase in shielding they're
pushing those electrons out a little bit
further and so the atomic size will
increase now this concept of principle
quantum number and shielding this
dominates when you're thinking about the
trend up and down so this dominates down
a group okay so if I ask the question of
which is bigger sodium or potassium
which has the larger atomic radius
between sodium and potassium well if you
look on the periodic table you'll see
that sodium is somewhere over here and
potassium is right below it so potassium
being right below it should be bigger so
potassium is bigger now what about cross
the periodic table well as the effective
nuclear charge right the positive charge
on electron feels as that increases the
outer electrons are drawn closer to the
nucleus they're pulled in closer so as
the effective nuclear charge increases
atomic size or atomic radius decreases
so a little bit of a visual for that if
we think about a situation where we have
just two protons in the center I mean
this don't assume that this is the
actual atom but we have two protons in
here in the nucleus and we have four
electrons ok so these
these two protons right here are pulling
on all these electrons right because
these opposite charges attract so let's
say that we added another proton all
right so now we have three protons and
we and we we also add one electron okay
what ends up happening is that because
we have more positive charge in the
nucleus that increases the the actual
nuclear charge and it also increases the
effective nuclear charge the the charge
that these electrons out here actually
feel is greater and so they're pulled in
towards the nucleus even closer so we go
from a situation where we have a larger
atom to a smaller Adam okay so as
effective nuclear charge increases as
the charge that these electrons outside
of the nucleus experience is is greater
than the atomic size will decrease now
this dominates across a period okay if
you notice as you go across a period the
atomic number increases you have more
protons and so more protons higher
effective nuclear charge okay now the
reason why this dominates across a
period because you're probably thinking
well you're also increasing the number
of electrons as you go from element to
element across the across the period and
that's true but because you're in the
same shell because in each period you're
in the same show there's a super small
change in in the in the shielding okay
because you're not adding an entirely
new shell but when you're going down a
group you're going from energy level
number one two three four five six
you're adding a new shell so shielding
dominates going down a group but across
the group if you're in the same shell
it's it's the effective nuclear charge
that you'll be considering so if you
want to rank fluorine barium silicon and
gallium from largest to smallest well
if we're one from letters as small as
you want to go from basically the bottom
left to the upper right okay so I'm
going to erase this portion here Oh
barium is down over here and then we've
got gallium somewhere over here and
silicon is somewhere over here and
fluorine is up in the top right so this
guy barium is going to be the biggest
then gallium and silicon and then
flooring okay so I'm going to put barium
is the largest then gallium and silicon
and flooring so I hope that makes sense
and I hope that was a helpful video
thanks for watching if you found that
video helpful don't forget to Like
comment subscribe and share with friends
thank you and happy studying